[Music]
what's up fool what's up fool podcast
welcome to the war zone full podcast
we're here every Wednesday live on
youtube.com 80c at 12:30 or get us on
Friday morning or Thursday morning or
some boy to Monday morning to do to the
podcast some people don't even know we
have a podcast so shout out to Alex the
large four always I'm walking into a
Apple store and making sure that every
iPad every every tablet every computer
every iPhone is subscribed to the what
so full podcast now we've been here all
year and we never asked us for anything
we don't ask you guys for money we
didn't ask you guys to come to the shows
you come cuz you wanted to go but like
always every Christmas I need everybody
to get on the iTunes get on the places
where you can comment on our podcast and
write something nice say hey guys thank
you for another great year Merry
Christmas
I love the podcast or hey guys
[ __ ] this podcast and [ __ ] you guys hope
this shows better next year okay
that's all that's also a comment good or
bad we need those comments okay unless
that's the only reason that's the only
way people know that you guys are out
there listening so that's it don't take
much just open up another window and go
amen
I love this show just for free you get
to listen to a word my wife into it now
that's got a thug's go thing on my own
show share with somebody
was fool we got a Joe Torre whatsoever
what about that huh yeah just go up
there man whatever right not just those
iTunes SoundCloud every platform
stitcher all of them have it did go on
YouTube do it for your man to God what's
up fool we got Lisa right here like JLo
over here what's up food from Elkhart
Indiana
what's up fool for blowing up we made it
to ATC we've been here for a while
Dante boy Steve Allen Mancini Jay Baer
rawness
[Laughter]
Omar Gonzalez good to see Lisa healthy
she can go before she can't go before a
black hole yeah it was close
as you can so man yeah there were more
blood than the last week than it was at
the OJ trial what's up fool
oh man well guess how Kody got that
yesterday last week in the valley and
Wednesday night thirty forty eight it
was 48 at 3:00 p.m. never done April
that's almost frosty cold right in
Riverside right like 45 47 but what to
him the valley man is like a hardened 20
we're [ __ ] talking about whether to
talk about what's up boo any shows
coming up yeah you've got Ontario which
is almost actually it's sold out all of
it seven shows 27 through the third way
black record what's in the record of the
Ray Davis
yeah those are the guys who are selling
eight to ten shows at comedy clubs and
we do there is a door to shows Thursday
sold out two shows
so three show Friday sold out he shows
Saturday so loudly to show Sunday and
then if if you go to find out what
Michael Blackson was doing he'll come
back just to Monday
do they have a little competition no no
nobody knows other people know what
anybody's doing yes uh yeah so we're
having that so they've got Ontario
that's sold out then we have Denver New
Year's Eve and Denver New Year's Eve
Paramount Theater and uh-huh with who
what do you mean with who Little Joe you
haven't told me it they stole a bubble
I'm checking with him that's right
I checked with him last night but he's
posted a big backup Johnny's coming
Rodrigo I don't know if Larry's coming
but I seen that movie you fooled with
tell me which one no one the homeboy is
in the fog the fog
well you're on about it you're also
coming to Bridgeport Connecticut
any brand so right after yeah stress
factory right after uh that much better
impact yeah you got all ready cuz you
guys are doing a turnaround that's like
going to Denver and you're leaving the
first come back and then you might be
leave in a second you know crazy travel
and at one time we did with homeboy on
with my gear missing flights yeah I see
you guys have tell me about the fog but
I didn't see that part where they cut
everybody with the string oh that's cold
that's gold [ __ ] oh man well you're
waiting for that I'm sorry but the fog
is scary huh yeah but it's an original
movie by a homeboy homegirl from a
Halloween oh because it's an original
fog
yeah yeah I totally look like that was
gonna go abroad ghost ship is the walk
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna watch it do that
she'll scary how would they probably get
caught with that do you guys watch
anything good
I've been watching the new mrs. Mazal
are the new a new season it's okay they
were to go to French friends French
Mademoiselle
yeah I've been watching frontier got to
the third episode of new season of what
frontier they're looking for Lord Benton
huh looking for his podcast yeah it
supposed to be ruthless come on anybody
in the [ __ ] new frontier bro but I
think we're gonna save it too like the
last couple episodes dude bit like Duda
but so do they be using those chicks for
everything all the women in all that
they have no choice bro do you like oh
it's crazy man I've been reading that
book that book um the other half not the
half not told which is like how slavery
was a real impact on the American
economy in the beginning oh that's where
we get all our cheese from dude okay but
they never talked about it right but it
wasn't all kind of slave like let this
leg our like give the price of cotton
would it go down the price of slaves
will go down there's all commodities
I'll revolved around that economy yeah
man
saw 48 hours that I saw regional with no
training places I saw one of the best
Christmas movies out there trading
places karate man so I was Isaac the
boob so I ended up pausing the rack I'm
very part of Bo Diddley bro yeah she
went from Halloween to that movie or
Halloween to judge the votes over within
this movie crazy a couple years but it's
funny I never knew she was Tony Curtis
is a daughter Kelly and Tony Curtis
Genelia Franz like a film royalty yeah
what a movie man she's married to
Christopher guest's oh really yes she
was you know they've been married
forever Lee
thirty years ugly covers only get the
hot chicks everybody always says hot
it's weird nah me neither I feel like
she's pretty but oh she's real pretty
and attractive in that movie was Arnold
Schwarzenegger total recorder we know
that's what I recall they're like spies
oh I know you talk to lies
true yeah true life but she actually
worked out for that movie to get her
body like Linda Hamilton in Terminator 2
yeah it's funny the first time I ever
seen titties was in commando when they
broke break through the hotel door how
was yours
that's the first time I received titties
mine was Porky's he said the mom's post
he's wanted to that was a crazy one huh
call a cop Porky's is bad
they always throw a like on need
unneeded like boob shot but it was like
a tip for the guys like hey guys I know
you like action movies but he comes with
areolas oh yeah I feel right about
commando bro but he's fighting that
black dude and I bring it to the house
and our dorky ass dude having sex that
was big blue one story yeah cuz they
just busted through the dorks are all
fighting dude ah also man boob shot was
there now Point Break bro when you break
into the main house the first one do
return man I don't care who it is
it doesn't matter bro but uh somebody
heating you without the bottom of your
foot barefoot hurts
[ __ ] hit that for woke up in the back
with that [ __ ] to the road a doctor a
clean shot in a little spot where it's
vulnerable you're done dude going down
that must be tough man like to like to
be in a movie movie scene and you know
that everybody's here boobs even the
guys who made snacks like why is he
there - now you should be over there
making sandwiches for lunch he's right
there all quiet
we go that they got was a banker
foregoing activity but but if you're a
big actor you know I want other perverts
out of the room but he's our best sound
guy isn't that how they did it for
Nicole Kidman and Tom Cruise in a Eyes
Wide Shut it was just him everybody want
to see how tall he was compared to him
she was holding a baby I heard that she
he got really upset when they were
having sex and um Nicole Kidman picked
up on Tom Cruise and raised him in a
year like lanky no black said he's a
little guy that's not really known for
being a little guy huh what's up fool
man they they canceled Nick Kevin Hart
bro for a tweet he did ten ten years ago
I don't know Twitter all that long
really that was ten did a background
check seven macadam busted out a bunch
of homophobic tweets from Amy Schumer
Chelsea has women it's different yeah
like it's super different totally
[ __ ] dude come on man
he's like a bit one of the biggest movie
stars right now I think every glasses
talking about they should I make him
hose down I'm gonna move the billion bro
last time somebody said that's true what
they're gay regrets your movie well I'm
gonna lie to you man if you had I don't
have to lies a fact the only way you're
gonna host Oscars if all of a sudden a
hundred million people went to go see
your comedy in one day or you were in
the hottest movie they just came out
like like crazy rich Asians the best hos
right now to a host of the Oscars will
be Aquafina
from the crazy rich Asian after finding
the Chinese girl sweet and Tiffany
Haddish
together you put Aquafina and Tiffany
Haddish in the next movie like a cop
movie that movies and get number one
it's gonna be the number one bootleg in
the hood - oh we were always talking
about Cagney and Lacey with Leslie Jones
and Tiffany the joseline and I thought
that our jazz singer what's-her-name the
beginning but Hollywood oh we want to
put a pretty person like if somebody
would play Rodrigo they would never get
together lose exactly Rodrigo they'll
get [ __ ] dead to me Brad
haroldo bro look it wasn't named bro
from Batman what's his name Ben Affleck
no the other one Val Kilmer no oh
three name kid the British guy American
Psycho Oh
Christian Bale okay Christian Bale to
get that foot hanging like taco trucks
yeah man and getting all kind of wait
they don't play well Geo Torres so these
deaf was playing a vibrator Jaime
yeah fifty pounds more I think like
seven table no no real we've seen that
we seen the trailer is where I believe
them for it was marinated I think um the
Christian Bale girl got really really
skinny to prepare that movie mechanical
but can't the machinist the machinery I
think I scared me dude I heard he didn't
even eat for like 60 days to just water
cuz the whole thing he watched a movie I
did he was that was big
now I was trippy do you watch movie yeah
I totally tripped out why the whole
thing he was doing at the end because he
was feeling remorse for running over
that person and I didn't understand till
the end it was a good movie but you know
pack a lunch
yeah well Christian very hard times I'm
gonna have to say no yeah that's the
only Christian be I don't like that was
that he played a good role oh I didn't
know he was a cholo bro it was just a
crazy homie you know the secret cool
stitches in there so I thought nolg
yeah then I'm you know at that bar for
no reasonable yeah it was a quick one it
was that bar like over here in Lincoln
Heights
yeah a.m. so what's up with the Academy
like what are they gonna do like
supposedly they're saying now they're
gonna do it without a host how they're
gonna do that a lot about to forget
regret she was trying to say that he was
to be the hole that wasn't gonna do blow
he couldn't deliver a joke but he's
gonna talk about a beer Tom Hanks was
hanging around or just do jokes like
come on man people are yellow who's that
we don't watch your comedy is always
like the Oscars always like somebody
writing for some stupid TV writer
writing jokes except like with Jamie
Foxx he brought his own crew on Riley
what writer the gay rodeo man Ricky
Jerry's come on we see we see the Ricky
terriers looking like the young one I
don't want to put him on blast two
minutes I kind of like talk to him until
everybody try to hold us bro who either
gonna get that girl I have a know
they're talking about Hannah Gatsby or
whatever
I probably gonna go young and like
malleable somebody they can just put a
script in front of and say just be this
boring host you know somebody like that
like you know survive terrorism you know
one of those Selena Gomez types you know
who's very tv-friendly hasn't been to
many scandals you know dozen Tony just
is you know they're too young to have
any scandals yet Russia parable no joke
yeah a lot of people don't want it
either don't don't somebody said Coria
quote your holcomb said that tiffany
turn it down really yeah yeah and then
there's somebody else said the rock
turned it down but I know that's true I
haven't seen it how much one of the
right weed bro the human obey to know
bob coggan that's not to do
yeah you later want to be white cholo
he's just like some white guy who grew
up in the same neighborhood that were
very the movie was made by the same guy
who did our training day huh
David Ayres so Brad knew it would like
his first film and watch no holiday in a
movie another podcast gave juice in
which one sorry amar sons
what's he was f away cuz I watched that
one day after sick came on father cholo
was a fool I was in Crete to you know I
haven't that's green one the Creed ones
real good dude it was a trip dude
watching that movie cuz I guess it was
one of its Creed side kids and he comes
out and then a the Creed the wife goes
over there and like you know brings a
man and then you know you get strained
by Wragge and stuff
supposedly it's real good my favor aki
is rocky one that's a brawl you don't
like the one with clubber lang doesn't
go under without - comical say one I
said I like 1 through 4 even yeah robot
or something well no there's a little
beginning of course cuz we're rich
and that's like paulie's robot or
something like it's a lot of jail yeah
so he's but I like for because he's
gotten soft and rested on his laurels
and he's just been doing commercials and
boxing and then Dolph Lundgren a
challenges and yeah so it begins like
you said I'll fight oh yeah so he gets
killed and then that's the whole that's
the end of all the Rockies to me that's
it yeah
to me that's it anything after that
stupid I do like the idea that he's
reinvented it through this Michael B
Jordan this do you think I'm wrong
that's been going that and ramble dude
come on aside from Rambo this is a guy
who knock him for his enunciation
doctored the draft and cheesy stuff you
know that he's done say what you will
about him and he created a lego rock II
and Stallone is that um if you were to
come up with a story like a story that
belong
- - rocky like you say you wanna do one
I want to do a clubber Lang story how
did clubber Lang get who is that there's
just a lone likes to scrip he'll say
let's do this
he owns that bro like like he's like
George Lucas but he likes he likes to
learn he owns a rocky movie like if you
were come with an idea just to do a
background movie just on [ __ ] Adrian
he'll do it that's badass you could you
just go back and go you know what let's
chill Rocky's shooting fights when he
wasn't when you were nothing when he was
I'm they were spitting at him but when
he was [ __ ] sweeping the [ __ ] ring
yeah those were though that was opening
scene you know the harsh times I never
like hey my best fart bro when I feel
kicking him out and then he come back
Kissin ass bro another - he's gonna get
a shot kissed you are bro but he see
that's only for the new him though he's
off he's uh that's a problem I never had
a manager but he came back and then like
he got pissed cause he was on his
emotions but then he went back outside
and grabbed a little old man clean so
that would never had a manager whatsit
Mickey didn't have a manager cuz
remember he had that picture of him when
he was young yeah and then he's all he's
all I know what I could do what we could
do for you
and then ended up doing it and he was
old school dude and then homeboy was a
southpaw - fool who was siloam rocky my
dad said that uh they forced a fool to
be a left-hander bro well he said my
grandfather would tie up his right arm
yeah you the left they did that to my
grandpa well why cuz he was left-handed
a lot of impact it was it was known as
sinister the left meant sinister and so
people who were left-handed were
encouraged to use their right hands but
you're talking about training and terms
of getting better on the other side yeah
yeah but they would but kids got
punished for using their left hands that
dude from the Texas tornadoes Flaco
Jimenez yeah they said that he was a kid
he had polio but he also had another leg
that wasn't straight so he tied him to a
piano leg and then that's how he started
playing music and that was told that
story is told to us but guy used to
it tastes Texas may he rest in peace I
got that goes that means close to stay
on dude that play was [ __ ] they kept
in that little spot he hung himself oh
yeah
because the story goes that he was
having a lot of problems and uh people
ripping him off going over there to do
the plumbing on the new place and then
like he'll give him my 10 20 G's they'll
skip out on here get another one then he
was having problems with the permits all
types of stuff and then in the end you
called it quits
Wow man but the man that was he had a
tear as a tortilla machine maker that
made like perfect large with tears like
like so close to tears I guess in a west
calder then but his came out perfectly
yeah and they weren't like too thick and
they weren't under thick you mean didn't
it was almost they were almost have made
almost I can't believe they're do like
as soon you set a table he'll give you
flour tortilla with a border first janna
and then and then it'll be a flour
tortilla with your meal flour to chill
your tacos you got a lot of flour
tortilla but we'd have to put up that
floor forty April [ __ ] butter just
melted on it huh I'm a badass Pedro but
that was good food if you don't take if
you have never tasted that you know
you're not you're vegan whatever but if
you have never had something like that
before
they don't know what it's about soaks
into that flour that butter is I've had
I heard Mexican food in our lay like
tacos whatever taco they do but but I
never had taco with flour tortilla and
right there they took it a little flour
tortilla and put that guisado
which was a red pork and I don't know
how what it was but they will put cheese
and it would melt yeah it's basically if
you ever want to get any wannabe version
of that you can get it at Baker's
probably the closest place because it
has a little like you know that lotion
kind of goose outside but to put like
cheddar cheese you know
dice uh you know shred it up but do that
thing well that stuff was bomb dude
super delicious man but it's funny they
put those around they all disappear okay
no offense but this part is it's hot
garbage do you think it'd be more
interesting since your car
but no a muhammad i have to do bridges
goal is something else do your own
podcast go watch TV you know there's
other things you could do which I'd
watch a podcast
you could have lower your pants put on
your penis and jerk off no please don't
actually just do it
you'll feel better just get some lard
whatever my hobbies are you sport yeah
so get some shortening Crisco Roy do
something bro this is this parking lot
about entertaining hey this was about
wasted an hour what's up with you guys
you guys kind of started a little vegan
revolution everybody's like busting out
vegan even cuts of vegan butter than
alpha roebuck top lip even this wannabe
cat everything's you're gonna live
longer huh
everybody's gonna get likes for the
likes
oh hey he was all whole food make little
changes in your life
adjustments little adjustments drop some
things here and there I suppose no
people that do it for a month and expect
instant change and my brother say I'm
gonna try to be good for a month they're
trying to see if they can hang you know
for that long without caving in it's
hard for people because they see it as a
whole year it's easier if you have like
a partner to do it with - yeah you can
you know my cousin used to like filter
in like three non meat meals each week
you know for dinner and that that's how
they did it they just like slowly come
exchanged all this funny brother she
killed me dog Oh like I was doing
something I went through my wallet and I
saw my photos of my dog rabbit they saw
this food for right no birthday party
yeah I need a photo they wrote her back
oh we're going to the Jon Lovitz Club
and you pulled out his photo yeah we're
late for a birthday party
I used a little bit hey Rico Sanchez I
don't know if fluffy has a special next
year he might he has a sitcom that
they're making go ask you but who go
eyes hear me tell my netflix feel to
it's just we're waiting for to hear what
it is this week what's up bulls try not
to Mario Cruz being is one to get rid of
them bring home the bacon
no Mario Cruz vegans don't want to do
that PETA is starting some stupid
[ __ ] nothing to do with vegans really
want everybody thinks is stupid as Peter
bro like the stupid ass Peter came out
and said you know like I'm hungry as a
dog or I'm hungry as a horse yeah I
could eat a horse
that's offensive language that you
shouldn't say that but like they're
totally serious with this thing this
like engine wings Wow if I was a
daughter of that piece of [ __ ] please
and they will be used my money to stop
people from saying I'm so hungry I could
eat a horse
man it's [ __ ] ridiculous man write to
me it's like if I was actually in the
pinna and I was doing all this stuff
donating money that would actually turn
me off and I was like cut off my credit
card all that hey but but you know what
they're not all to turn up or take dogs
like squishy bro they know they're
trying to rescue little dogs but they
want you to [ __ ] stop eating yeah
they're on a larger they're on a higher
level in terms of like awareness stuff
rather than the street level of stuff
that you actually need which is helping
to save these animals helping with like
free spaying programs and that sort of
stuff you know like masks like like pigs
and chickens on about this yeah there
are the larger scale
they've been accused of dealing like
terrorist stuff right yeah it was a big
euthanizing are supporting euthanasia
for dogs and cats who are strays and
like you know instead of really having
rescues and no-kill shelters think they
feel like they're they'd be better off
just being killed you know being
euthanized so there's an argument
against that as well you know they've
got also to with that whole thing taking
pictures of those big old like
slaughterhouses Supreme Court says you
can't do that right you know my I had a
friend I worked with his dad worked for
the FDA and they barely like sometimes
they wouldn't even look at the floor at
the killing floor
they wouldn't even enter it and it would
they would just talk and say hi to their
contact over there at the company and
then that I can't control that this is
from the main thing it's not connected
so uh yeah so they would the FDA would
just come in and say hi chitchat
whatever and fill out their form and
then leave and they wouldn't look at
anything and then the whole the if you
when you go in the office like it's all
blocked off the killing floor is not
visible and so there's there's no way
that for them to even come in and like
sneak a peek and it's yeah like shuttle
Adrian Irma Paula death for cats reminds
some I need you feeling but you could
rather bad if you like no you Gonzales I
was in the movie cellular but yeah Bobby
be a bit ba Baracus you see that one
that one photos he was in that movie we
didn't never seen him never sorry I'm on
the phone in the van he's always grocery
shopping on Saturday and she did at the
bags on the floor didn't put him on top
and squishy came in and we're gone they
were God and she grabbed herself a
little bag of meanie big was well well
many bagels she ate them all she carried
that bagel bag over to her bed and then
she must have gone back for the
grapefruit because she can't carry both
then she had the grapefruit and she put
that on her bed - but she didn't eat it
cuz she barely has any teeth left so she
didn't tear that open but she tore the
bag of bagels open in 812 many bagels
Babli huh let's worry about how she got
mad dog gross you guys were feeding her
like a little burger or something piece
by piece
oh yeah she's used to eating like a
whole burger burger after a bath because
it's so funny to go to a dark night and
it's not poking it yeah so this time
like we're both together so I gave it a
SUP piece and I took a piece so we gave
her four little pieces instead of giving
her so she didn't know that I don't
think she got she's expecting stood away
for the big piece yeah I don't think she
got it but this was the posture so she
waited for me and waited for me then I
didn't know what's going on then I went
to a pee and she was over there moping
in the hallway all sad can I live with
triple bombs
I see people like that don't even though
they borrow oblivious I believe you're
like ways that he was Barbie with
confidence oh you said about fools up
there bombing and an athlete didn't bomb
it like rostov stupid a Paul Rodriguez I
did I was sorry for God bro man awful do
the Easter Day Parade and guess who was
there the actor from blood him from
Boulevard Knights which one the older
brother though it was straight we can
guess yes there was puppet right over
there no well that may be true cool to
co-write with Taylor the past but then
his older brother went along here
that guy was at UH at the parade still
looking good
hell yeah old man he look like an older
actor you could tell he's an actor right
away yeah that's the way carried himself
scarifying recognized me and you had
just way too much personality weird like
it turned it on yeah well a lot of look
away yeah food enter the Boswell's
they're not sort of my bad
then a Trejo cap gee big boy
sad water at all float Danny Trejo has
some blue sweet blue velvet shoes like
bedroom slippers but you know the fancy
kind he were wearing those with Ali Rams
shirt they're in first place when I walk
is on blue state Stacy Adams yeah you
also ran into an old friend right
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I ran into the guy that
heckled that was heckling his comedy
show yeah I was making everybody laugh
he'll getting more laughter the
comedians and now I saw that fool he's
part of the Volkswagen bus club and
that's what I brought you the heckler
that's been told these guys hey tell him
how [ __ ] up Jeff Garcia you recognize
him okay cool but then you realized who
he was he looks a little different from
that picture but he was funny he
nicknamed homeboy the tow truck driver
dude that was so hilarious dude you got
job talk yeah you know whatever he also
uh he gave Garcia a hard ass time this
is how bad that dude bomb he's backing
on his legs then uh he's a hunk I don't
even know you tell everybody what kind
of razors you used a he's off hey doggie
gonna stop or what [ __ ] antenna so
this dude bombs gets off stage mean he
goes up to Felipe next and he goes
handle attack I'm coming to Denver on
November no I'm coming to the west of
Denver or New Year's Eve December 31st
at the Paramount Theater we're
partnering with our pot guide the
leading online guide to find
dispensaries for two for two for 20
friendly
lodging lodging can large in cannabis
events dispensaries deals and more pot
guide is helping me put together a meet
and greet on December 21st it's going to
be at the peak dispensary stop by from
4:00 to 6:00 p.m. for a photo saying hi
to get a half grab join for a penny what
give me a Lincoln so if you're gonna be
a denver come by 4 to 6 p.m. on the 21st
and the 21st at peak dispensary and get
your half grab joint coming to the show
in Denver but we hope you come to the
show too
this was a large in Lhasa you can't read
lodging 420 friendly lodging so they
have a list of 420 friendly like
apartments and condos totally on that
one
yeah so Merry Christmas
yeah bad so the motels now that
unfortunately friendly in some places
that are where it's recreationally legal
you know what I mean so do check your
pugs Escalade hitting a boho friendly
for you guys you know like if you want
to smoke in the rooms and all that stuff
and they don't have or they have a patio
that's 420 friendly you know stuff like
that I think any kind of smoke in the
rooms is not a good idea kind of stinks
over time yeah no matter what it's been
and whether its tobacco right so I would
have like little lounge a couple little
lounge as if it were my hotel section
and like the lounge with the windows
open
yes I'm sort of yeah it did have there
all day all day a bar just like a hotel
has a bar you know the sister nobody
showed there's a guy there a big
southern cockroach because the other big
money to like anything if you were to
have like homemade something just
available
cuz I'm partying
homemade anything what they were making
today all manage it me this badass
yellow nobody I hate that bro but I need
to taste it be surprised with you in
your heart yeah we're like one of the
goodest thing I ever made hottest I
don't have [ __ ] to make first of all I
just had Jack tuna and tortillas so I
got me my I got me a flat a flat
tortilla bro I put out I made my tuna on
the side like with mayonnaise tomatoes
onions jalapenos and I spread it on my
tortilla and then I put Monterey Jack
cheese in it I folded it I put a lot of
butter and oil and I fry that
[ __ ] - I got crunchy and ain't
for 200 she like kiss of the other
brother Oh crunch you're good you're
good
fool when I bit into it some of the baby
was coming out of the bottom burn me
Lisa what you don't like it I don't like
hot tuna that disgusts me you stop it -
mom I just would never mix it with a
tortilla though I mean I'll probably
have a different outcome if it was like
that okay the aristocrat here my first
time we do you're going without right
Frenchy stop Pedro and Manzano oh my god
dude I don't know [ __ ] about no daddy
dog I don't know [ __ ] up I know daddy
I don't know [ __ ] about how big the
[ __ ] sandwich is gonna be so I order a
tuna melt didn't even I thought about a
cool didn't even fold it you close it
roll open it was big ass toast was a big
ass [ __ ] melted melted and they put the
big ass like I was like our ice cream
scoop of a [ __ ] tuna top row and I
couldn't even close it actually like
Pippi Longstocking bro like us like a
wafer yeah that's how it
yeah yeah melt is supposed to be like
it's supposed to you have a fork or
knife or like that like it one time I
only had like six avocados and bred and
managed the only has that's a lot so I
had a whole thing of bread so I just
toasted the bread put mayonnaise on it
hey that's what I ate today I toasted
toast and again I got the whoever called
Oprah batteries this time so what a
beginning what do you like Cubans down I
put a big anaise did I put a tomato on
top then this thing had these heirloom
tomatoes put it right on top and best
pepper and then horse out forget about
it
but you know what I put two jalapeno
you've been hella pain everything he
puts all the pain you want everything
even if it's like Italian food pasta
Asian food it just doesn't make severy
thing to say jalapeno the jalapeno
revolutionize Peter tells me and you do
it before you even try the food I put do
what time I got the leftover spaghetti
and I [ __ ] microwaved it with two
slices of cheese and I [ __ ] cook the
flour tortilla and I put it a tortilla
we've got paid you brought you a good
pickled jalapenos right yeah do you ever
um you ever do fresh jalapenos
I wrote I have fresh jalapenos for you
my love I haven't tried to roast it yeah
I just slice them fool put them on top
it just gets you hot and it goes away in
like five minutes oh yeah it's good it's
good on pizza but it depends when they
get pickle dude sometimes they lose a
kick I like to one have a little bit
right and if they get over pickled
that's like it's like just it's like
yeah it's like I don't like I don't like
the fresh jalapenos on pizza I got angry
when they sent them with the pickled
whoa mama dude I thought you're gonna do
them fresh like last time we don't have
any well [ __ ] that noodle or eating
maybe any kind of colloid is too and if
somebody puts the [ __ ] pick jalapenos
well [ __ ] nasty boy to be fresh yeah
yeah yeah yeah a diced up
that's how we numb or the little one
those serrano ones there isn't even a
little hotter so you need two jalapeno
wrong now like I just dip it in salt all
right and I like the little serrano ones
which are harder to you know eat a
little one or two you know so if it
can't do hot ones cuz its wings somebody
asked if you would do hot ones I don't
know if it's there you go Whataburger
double meat with cheese and bacon I've
had two I've had I never had the water
burger know what me with cheese and
bacon but I've had that take the big
text mixed with jalapeno is that the one
that comes in that Texas toast you know
how we do it Lisa made um jalapeno
what poppers no jalapeno cakes Oh
corn muffin cornbread with hey what's
the name of that sauce he had on those
chips as we can use that [ __ ] you sauce
but that was our onion or onion flavor
but bro get the cheap portly and get
your original wine and get the hot
opinion ones yes yes not traitors but
when they go when they go out of state
they don't write bitching because I get
people get off and anything oh really
they cause I'm gonna just call it our
sauce what so boom well if they make
vegan ones for vegans that's great but
we can't just go on hot ones they got a
book you so tell them the book Felipa
hot ones let's not show you hot wings or
whatever oh but they said something it's
have done it the Christmas shopping for
you kid me too about anniversary is
tomorrow we're opposed to like playing
up a have a big party and we're gonna
have a party this weekend and then we're
gonna have a party on the 15th but we
had it all planned out then he said to
get up hysterectomy I did how did you
feel the last month I felt like [ __ ]
over the last two months but really
blood right I was losing blood but I
think his bro I think that the Lakotas
kid
I was well I had no color my lips were
completely colored chef I thought I was
gonna faint with everything else what's
going on well I had a miscarriage a
fourth miscarriage in two years but I
think that's the problem and in terms of
how I felt in the past couple years
really the past year I think all the
back-to-back miscarriages caught up with
me and I think I lost a lot of blood
anyway but this last week or two weeks
I'd been losing a lot of blood because
since the the miscarriage they said I
had a what's called a mole a molar
pregnancy which is like this one in a
thousand you say
one and a thousand women get it and it's
like um you get a remnants of your it
not it wasn't even a fetus it was just
the sac and placenta pieces and stuff
like that that's all I had in there
there was no baby but when they took it
out there they I guess didn't get all of
it so there's some pieces that remain
and it tries to it's almost like a
symbiote in venom like it tries to get
into the other parts of your body and it
can what can cause cancer so and it
loves to go to the lungs so we carried
that for a month yeah so me too so we
were worried about that and then my
uterus was getting bigger and bigger it
was the size of a [ __ ] jawbreaker
they saw a magic multi in the big ones
no I mean it was like 10 centimeters
wide which is really big it's like
double the size it should be but when
it's not pregnant but but anyway so I
was bleeding a lot and a lot of clots
and stuff and really gross like coming
out and but I had two huge accidents
what in bonds right one at Vons and I
had to leave Vaughn's like with stuff
coming out of my shoes I mean it was it
was brutal and I had to run out of the
store and my son had to take care of the
rest of the transaction and I was like
I'll just meet you at the car I had a
whole bunch of groceries and everything
he said was driving like um like harvey
keitel Reservoir Dogs yeah yeah it was
and Isaac was freaking out you have
blown up or outside the house into the
driveway and everything it was
everywhere but it would go back I have
to like help her with her pants
there were blood somebody stabbed with a
sword between her legs I just heard a go
I didn't know what to do and I like but
you have to I like to the pants off to
over a trash can put them in a bag and
then I'd lost my favorite shoes too
because they were ruined but it was
anyway but yeah so I lost a lot of blood
but I was supposed to have surgery
already on Wednesday but on Wednesday
morning when I woke up as I had to fast
for the surgery too so there's no way
for me to replenish the all the blood
the hemoglobin so I get there and my
blood is already four units below normal
the beginning of the normal range which
is like twelve mine was eight when we
started surgery well they did start
surgery like that he thought it was okay
but then after surgery I was recovering
okay but I was like I still feel like
not just I could tell it wasn't the
drugs it was something else I just felt
like I didn't have any life in me and
they but that's why we cancelled because
I had to get fluids that was one thing
cuz you weren't allowed I was allowed to
drink water either because I was fasting
for the surgery and I'm supposed to go
completely but my body was so depleted
from the last week or two weeks and
before that so I really I felt like I
was gonna die and then after they did
the surgery they gave me a blood
transfusion when I was laying there and
I was awake when it was happening we
were just it took like four hours slowly
I felt like a different person and I
still do I feel like I have energy like
I haven't had in a couple years I feel
awesome I feel positive I feel happy
like just sitting there doing nothing
and so I'm glad we went through it but
it was tough on Wednesday that's it was
a surprise cuz I called and I said I
feel like I'm gonna faint and she'd say
you should go to the emergency room that
was the purse because I was like am I
still gonna have surgery like all this
is happening the same day it was a mess
and it was like karma you waited a long
time right
I waited two hours I was supposed to
start at 4:30 and surgery started at
6:30 so that produced a lot of anxiety
man I didn't like that you know energy
you saw before the birth that fusion
right yeah yeah no I just wanted some
water or something I was like I want
something to drink
no take your old result well that's
because I didn't sign consent because
you're like better to read of course
okay you're like this I didn't sign what
if you have no what to read it for you
well I didn't sign it because it was a
little different than what he had said
and he was saying that they were gonna
take my ovaries too and I said no no
because that means I start men up
was right after this and I'm not ready
for that like I haven't prepared myself
for that and if they take my ovaries
that's what's gonna happen and that's I
said that's not what we discussed that's
not what we discussed
so the doctor finally got there and then
he's like I know it's not what we
discussed but if I don't he said so he
changed the wording just slightly it's
saying if involved if the ovaries are
involved in the whole nurse down there
they he would have to cuz he said I
can't wake you up and have you signed
consent and then go back in there he
said so this allows me to do it if it's
necessary said well you got to write if
it's necessary no we didn't talk about
that as a possibility so I was so afraid
but I got to I was the first question I
asked and I know I was drugged up but
she goes okay Lisa we're taking you back
to your recovery room she's like you did
great everything's great and I said do I
still have my offer no it was really
hard and I went back around one right or
two no I went back after her surgery at
8:30 cuz they stopped on the visitation
cloth at 8:00
yeah but they made an exception yes
surgery was so late they were offering
you to stay overnight yeah they made me
a little bit yeah I'll do it
but we have to go as you go back and
take care of the dog I have to go back
and feed the dog and walk the dog and I
had to go feed the bunnies yeah pull out
to get a bad boy I went home and I said
man she gonna have no food to eat right
there
she's vegan close to they don't save you
fooled by the way they all you're gonna
yeah so I want to go I want to go I made
it is what you went to [ __ ] and now it's
Friday to get the medicine and then you
know I wasn't there hi what's not doing
Christmas shopping too little house a
little bit how the Christmas decoration
were half off so [ __ ] it do whatever
[ __ ] at home so I got with
that's a little house and I bought a
bunch of snacks cookies and I bought her
this soup
there was actually a vegan it was uh it
was Italian vegetable soup with beans
yeah I've been there but when I tasted a
handle flavors had to put my own smoke
flavor and I put on salt and I boiled it
and I put in that Joe Rogan Yeti yeah
bro yeah were you up there doing
push-ups Felipe I want to get these for
us to miss Caulfield thing hot it's
unbelievable or whatever it's cool but
that stuff it's almost like it has
batteries like you're surprised how cold
that stuff will get worse - yeah my soul
I boil in the water and I took all the
coffee smell out of it and I put it with
soup and it's that there and Jewish when
she came out of it
they gave her first of all they gave her
the hardest drugs you can get to a man
there was oxy there was meat a lotta and
more and more things I was like I was
there bro Feeny I did not like I don't
like the way that was way out bro cut
you off it makes my eyes feel like
they're just so heavy
Thomas Joe who want to be there hi I
know I'm trying to come out you know I'm
trying I feel like I'm trying to climb
out of the what do you call it like the
torpor the the sleep that pulls you in
you know I don't feel like that feeling
like I'm trying to talk Oh her eyes she
notice I needed it I knew that I so bad
I'm so thirsty that's a that's what you
get for anesthesiologist right yeah the
whole dry mouth yeah and of course the
tubing you know had scratch my throat
because so I felt like I had us
throw for a day maybe tailor hospital I
would say powerful power had the best
ice were sodas it's clean air they
actually use real water in there alright
man you know you can have a whole
podcast but just on the people who are
there waiting for the for their sick
ones Pro at the waiting office no
[ __ ] should be inside bro but
when we first got there to emergency
room my surgery the emergency rule the
ER of any put this way this hospital
praise chapel no Providence which Holy
Cross Holy Cross a lot of amalah only
brother Valley is Catholic right there
all industry cholos dried blood the guy
taking patients in and taking
temperature whatever you said that they
thought that you had a baby student did
well the problem is I had to explain all
this along the wake so there's a so rare
because there's a catch because it's a
Catholic it's a Catholic hospital so
they have they they have a policy and
they don't do abortions right but this
isn't an abortion but the doctor had to
justify and clarify to the hospital that
this was not an abortion like she's not
really pregnant because I had to take a
pregnancy test before all this stuff and
I said well why do I have to take a
pregnancy test because because the all
those remnants make my blood level show
that I'm pregnant and that's in during
the ologies my biology is saying you're
pregnant I have all the symptoms
everything and it's rare and it's hard
to explain that to somebody who doesn't
understand I've never heard of it before
I never heard of it before I thought
childbirth for years I chase what are
they yeah or they're making this
schedule or whatever so she though you
have to take it before your CT scan and
I said yeah but it's gonna be positive
so then what do I do am I gonna get
rejected I'm not gonna be able to take
my scan she's like well I have no idea
so I had to talk to all these people
then they finally called my doctor I
said just call him he knows why
like we there are two doctors I'm
dealing with who know this
I know this everybody else who's dealing
with this should know as well or should
at least understand what I'm saying here
so I wanted that that took a long time
it was a lot of policy I actually yeah
so but those but having to explain all
that was really tough you have to be
calm but push you that that that that
gurney like like Michael Corleone you
can't get crazy it's like being at the
airport you'll get locked up but your
credibility is gonna go out the window
too and so anything you ask for you're
gonna be seen as the crazy guy no and
you're not gonna get any attention and
they're gonna remember you next time
it's funny too with all the employees so
many room for mistakes dude yeah so
they're reading my chart and my try know
what's in my chart because we share the
chart at home like it's all online so I
know that what's in my chart and then
they're reading it and then they kind of
put it together and they see oh and I
said yeah I said you know what that your
system needs is like a paragraph about
what the problem is that summarizes all
this stuff in the charts like if you
look at each of the charts but somebody
shouldn't have to do that at first
glance right right you pull it up you
know 46 year-old woman you know pregnant
you know signs of pregnancy but not
pregnant you know stuff like that you
know has a molar pregnancy which
indicates you know but the doctor turned
to me and he said I had to really fight
for this mine and another case this
month
he said because they thought I was
terminating pregnancies so like two and
one month and he had to justify this he
said you know it's a religious hospital
and everything I said yeah that's crazy
though and imagine all the people don't
have anything with my care Wow crazy man
I'm glad you're feeling better you you
were like I don't know what's gonna
happen to you the second I was all
worried yeah man whatever when I got
home and you went through the house for
so big very depressive isn't into
Charlie Brown music
you're not there luckily Shelley was
there to help - mm-hmm your sister
Shelley helped a lot yeah she did all
the work stuff and took picked up Isaac
when I needed it
I'll try to get to go visit abroad again
stop bye bye bye [ __ ] now bye [ __ ]
now those dudes that pick up the pace
the pictures they throw in another bed
those big dudes ordered their fans the
doctor with a [ __ ] bro no no he's a bad
guy he was the scientist guy damn bro so
much blood probably really somebody like
impaled you yeah my body's amazing man
didn't hurt it's just a gusher the
budget without you knowing it you know
what I don't know no I know yeah I know
it's gonna be bad for you back out of my
body gotta do this to get better
ion I have a feeling that if I cuz this
is the fourth one and all the first
three were all molar pregnancies but
they everything left my body and I had
natural miscarriages this fourth one I
decided to have a DNC and have it
surgically removed
there's no baby I was like let's just
clear it out it'll be more predictable I
don't have to go through these problems
with like a regular miscarriage but I
did and and it continued and I feel like
I wouldn't my body would have cleared
everything out if it had done it on its
own but with the DNC I think it left
parts in there and I think that was
where I made the mistake you got a blood
transfusion before the surgery no after
you guys visited after you and Isaac
were there they that's when I started to
do surgery on the phone yeah I feel I
started doing stuff right away I mean if
I'm sore and I have to be careful like
doing too much or pulling you know
pulling the dog or like thinking doctor
said to hit that though
that's right well you got asked all
right I'll tell that's corner I got
laparoscopic surgery so oh that was the
worst part
so there was overlap this know they they
fill up your abdomen with air and then
they put a camera in there least I
could've got released but she needed to
pass gas she was blown after the surgery
they put carbon dioxide in the air in
your body she was a pain it was what's
worse than labor pain was worse than
childbirth it was worth it was horrible
I was walking around the floor at night
like can I get a gas ex anything no they
didn't they have to get like doctor's
authorization for [ __ ] gas don't like
fools to stay young and a lot of like
people to have a lot of money because I
don't like to do the pepper is also that
ex-leader from I've heard that yeah I
mean the next time I feel worn down like
that don't have my blood checked I'm
gonna see if there's something that
electively that I can do like that
because it made all the difference I
felt like I feel like I maybe have not
felt this way in five to six years like
longer than blood the gear he would be
one happy both laughing I don't know I
feel great yeah and it just like to be
that low on blood from I think it was
the four miscarriages back because I
lost a lot of blood with those other
ones so I they talk about blood y'all
should have had Toby here maybe have
those parents who you wasn't over there
being above table
no somi got so buzz he did not pronounce
C's because you were the blood so he was
not come for your bum for a ball
Oh your last name is bore tears alone i
keyboardist two gang banging into
literacy their family he was bleeding
but rollable that's your lip chap stick
that you left open on the table chewy
ate it squishy ate it she broke it
she broke it open and ate although
[Laughter]
because the bunnies was the cords and
what else clothes and like little
shoelace and this is my second pair of
it the other one
grover ate the string actually three
pairs i have another white one the other
ones but the god wants to meet the
rabbits with we can't tell because she
does lick her lips she won't hurt him
but I just bite a little I feel like the
rabbits might hurt her and she'll try to
goose and then she might like you know
get nervous so we have to but do you
feel better like whatever Sam I feel a
hundred percent got that God Antonelli
well I mean I'm sore like I'll have a
little you know I have I have pain here
in my incision but but I feel great
personally like inside feel awesome
someone said Oh Maura was not as if
someone needs to draw these are higher
meds I didn't take it for very long I
really don't like that I asked for the
ibuprofen diluted like in Drugstore
Cowboy exactly dilaudid but I'm better
bottled they had what
yeah but they don't give that much I
think you'll expect probably huh I don't
even know yeah they put it and mix it
with the solution it's but you don't
you're not that kind of I think you like
the peppier with that and you go like
Michael Jackson style yeah but if you
help I don't like to be I don't want to
go to sleep never wake up every once in
a while I might be a little good nappy
nappy no so Tyra G when I got back from
Arizona for Tempe now therefore we had a
lot of night before we even started the
week though yeah Matt was dressed but I
would sleep well the night before this
what'd you leave to wear Eileen I'm
eleven but I left I took off to the
airport at 8:45 with um I called this
for a t30 nothing phones off so he went
on his own like I'll call you in the
morning you know like me I like to take
care of it just so yeah I run into any
stress nothing you're just there waiting
an hour before your flight and his phone
was off I was like dude I gotta take off
I'm gonna calm one more time I went to
go get coffee at Starbucks call my cell
did he make it
I'm sure to a march of reso 3031 I think
and she turned 30 I remember Johnny
rookie last what is he talking about
he's 31 like you know what somebody's
like a year older than me but looks
younger than you so see older than
Johnny then that means he's 32 yeah
Johnny's how full saying like all like
in a bit spice be your home yeah that's
funny help I did it's now well how old
you are it's what you look like
what you look like and who Jackie you
were oh I know some fools they're like
you know they were young but they look
old man I know man I fool you asked you
a raven or table row 28 it was like 28
or 29 goddamn dog in the 30s for what
he's not 28 you're lying
29 Raymond ortho
no he's got to be 40 at least there's a
picture of Wincy Adams I think is he a
president when he was 17 this guy look
like he was 40 years old yeah oh yeah
because I mean that's back then well
used to work with you though
oh and that picture he was 17 but he
look like was 45 ritchie valens how old
he looks like I mean it was tough back
there bro like guys gonna ask you for a
duel yeah but like Richie Valens he was
on those kids before he went to school
they had him out there picking oranges
yeah remember though the picture of him
and the picture of the real Donna the
real vision yeah it's like you got to
remember these kids weren't even done
with high school yet yeah man when he
died I don't like all his pictures are
before he was 17 and it's like how can I
be when I was a little kid my mom would
go pick up my aunt's will go with her go
pick him up they were in high school
they were straight up men in high school
they look like they were in the Eagles
mustaches a little shirt open like dude
like straight up men my dude like you
look at high school kids look like I
yeah I was gonna pick up Isaac but there
was like some kids in high school we had
beards yeah there are a couple there are
a couple I don't know that's the guy
that would buy the beers
yeah Isaac's probably gonna be babyface
guy that look like a real short 20 by
Road yeah yeah he's just tall yes he's
gonna have a baby face for a while I
think his dad has a baby face - so
what's up fool so you feeling all right
I'm feeling great I'm feeling great I
don't want to bring the podcast down but
yeah it was pretty serious last week and
I don't know if we're gonna have a
podcast around Christmastime
yeah yeah maybe I'll have tamales and
pizzoli and be real
little eyes burdensome to the podcast
corner on and so a big burner does can I
get some more on
promoting his [ __ ] bro he was he say
that he was there now I don't know
forgot where he was but it was somewhere
over there have no weed and then he said
they had the better weed there who
burner yeah he's good right yeah I don't
know I had us I don't know thing I had
it was alright there's a little taste
issue for me to say whether when you
know you get people's product but they
they themselves have the really good
weed yeah and that's a weed I wanna
smell yeah your secret stash
yeah money like when you go to a dope
dealer the weed guy goes on my list for
my personal stash bro start sign a
personal stash Stevie's personal stash
is better than others - oh well he has
like you know some rags that you got
those dudes that go there and sniff it
out there's some people hanging around
for free weed though you gotta have some
good stuff to give to those I saw the
best video ever man I saw the guy
driving and it will try beat anybody
crap there's uh this pre-roll somebody
gave me but it's ripping to get in the
air man if you give me a pre row pretty
much it's all shake you're the one that
we had that I think we gave Jerry one at
one time and then I smoked well now in
front with the tophat I'm not sure if
that was something else it might have
been before that though I can't remember
but I lit it up and it went it's cool
cuz my even if the weeds dry oh right
it'll still taste good yeah but the weed
shitty and dry it was like the Christmas
vacation cooking the turkey to be on dry
one of the Chi will come back brother
full item zero two away
he'll be back man Toby was just on his
podcast I saw that for he little ball of
diable
oh those like Orangina bottles or
something like that was it a bomb like a
homemade bomb a bomb
what's a fool shout out to George Perez
stories the scumbag are were with [ __ ]
I'm siding Eddie mega man hour with the
mega man yeah man with Rodrigo Torres yo
yo yo yo yo
with Marty Moreno and also what's up boo
podcast and that's it go Steelers dope
dealers podcast drama club thanks for
having your podcast Frankie from oh no
no thanks for the invite Freddy correct
Edwin and his wife still have one - what
am i eating
- but you I know oh my god so much is
always terrible terrible they they hit
you bro and you ain't doing nothing I
never gotten messed up by those I've
gotten messed up only by the stars
Foubert stop lie with her edible
everybody has the best weed now dog stop
do you know right that was me
yeah we should what's up fool take your
time for having for listenin to us all
here in the podcast thank you happy home
we might be skipping an episode here
here they're skipping episode here and
there so hopefully you guys will write a
good review on a podcast thank you very
much Lisa for sharing hear your story I
know it was tough I don't know how
you're gonna chair it but I'm glad
you're alive I love you I will see you
guys later G go that one's for week guys
it was a Yemen yeah man thank you